Okay.
I want to talk about the war,
uh,
up through 1916 today and then,
um,
followed by 1917 and 1918 I on Wednesday,
on the last day of his life as John Jr has a,
was a troubled about what he was going to write in new many t the,
the paper of the,
of the socialist a,
a party about whether a workers of France should go to war against workers,
uh,
um,
of,
of Germany.
I,
and he,
his decision,
I wish for that matter had been taken earlier anyway,
not just that evening.
Uh,
it reflects a,
what is called the Sacred Union,
a union south cray that,
uh,
the political parties put aside their differences,
um,
in the war effort,
in the mobilization of,
uh,
of the total war that world war one a would become.
And so he did,
he wrote an article with the headline called Onovo,
uh,
forward,
or let's go,
or,
uh,
anyone out to eat in a cafe called lukewarm,
which is still there.
It's not called request home anymore.
Uh,
and he was having a meal and about to go back to,
uh,
his newspaper offices right near there.
It's near the boulevard.
Mamacita,
um,
were a lot of newspaper offices still are.
And a right wing nut put a pistol through the,
uh,
from outside through the curtain into the restaurant and,
and,
uh,
blew him away.
Um,
there was a tremendous of turmoil in the street and,
and,
and people who remembered it,
including a I,
the writer,
a [inaudible] Guy,
I remember this,
this sort of,
this her swell of,
of,
of chaos,
but also of apprehension in the sense,
in a sense.
I mean,
it's easy to read this backwards nostalgia,
but the sense that things would never be the same again.
Uh,
and you know,
Joe has jr has jr has forever.
Angela has a,
uh,
died and,
and,
uh,
the world,
went,
went to war.
Um,
and the way the war started,
uh,
started as if the,
in the way that the military planners had wanted to start.
I left you last time with the Schlieffen plan.
Uh,
and Schlieffen,
uh,
literally on his deathbed said that the last German soldier,
his sleeve should touch the,
uh,
the Mar,
the,
uh,
the mosh,
the English Channel,
uh,
and that in order to put,
put France into a headlock,
put Paris into a headlock like that,
you should sweep this way through Belgium.
They'd eliminated the Netherlands as part of that invasion route that would come
and World War II.
Uh,
but they didn't need the Netherlands.
In this case.
They would march into
neutral Belgium neutral sense,
1831,
uh,
knowing that this would bring,
the British into the war because the British could never have Belgium,
a occupied by a,
uh,
a potentially very hostile,
power.
Um,
and so Germany is under pressure to win the war quickly.
Uh,
they,
as I said at the end of the last time,
well,
that's lecture.
They anticipate about two weeks.
It's going to take,
uh,
the big Russian bear to bring all of these,
these forces,
uh,
in many cases using that single track railroad,
they went all the way to Vladivostok,
uh,
to,
prepare to invade a Germany or to defend against a German incursions,
uh,
into,
into Russia.
Uh,
and so it was this,
someone once said,
and I don't remember who is of Schlieffen,
is dead hand automatically,
uh,
pulled the trigger,
when,
uh,
the German,
when the,
when the Belgian government on the 2nd of August,
uh,
rejected German demands of that his armies could march through Belgium,
and the Belgian army a fought bravely,
uh,
indeed very heroically against a overpowering military strength,
big fortress of,
of,
uh,
of the edge.
Uh,
when it gets to a close here,
I can't see,
but when the edge there,
uh,
falls,
and,
uh,
falls to the young,
not so young,
but well,
commander,
uh,
alughten Dorf,
after a huge,
a bombardment on the 16th,
uh,
followed by the fall of Namu.
And once,
uh,
the Germans get through,
you know,
the hills of eastern Belgium,
uh,
then,
they,
uh,
move,
fairly,
uh,
quickly,
but the German commander,
von Moltke,
Mol t,
k,
e,
the younger multi,
uses some divisions to try to pin down the Belgians.
Uh,
and he also is having doubts with a view toward the home front of,
uh,
of wanting,
of fearing how far the French in there never will penetration of Alsace Indo
else last Uren,
uh,
would go,
it's over indeed franchise advances in El Sauce,
although they had been anticipated by Schlieffen as inevitable and not crucial
to the winning of the war,
uh,
in a very timely fashion,
now lead a von Moltke to transfer,
uh,
troops,
fearing that the homefront might despair of French advances there.
And so what this means is that the Germans have basically fewer troops than had
been anticipated,
uh,
in,
the original,
uh,
in the original plan,
by,
uh,
von Schlieffen.
And sure enough,
the British,
the British expeditionary force,
which was not a large army,
finally arrives on the 20th of,
of,
uh,
August,
more,
um,
uh,
in,
um,
in southern and in Belgium.
Uh,
but everybody's fairly sure that the war is going to be over,
um,
a fairly soon.
But one of the things that happens immediately now,
how do I do this?
One of the things that happens almost immediately is that the Germans are
marching,
Socorro so quickly and so rapidly,
uh,
that they become a fatigued,
by,
uh,
the pace of their march.
And also problems,
uh,
with,
with communications.
Um,
and in,
in indeed the army,
the command,
the army is commanded by I forgettable guy called Kook.
Uh,
it's spread too thinly across a wide,
uh,
front.
Uh,
and that fitness made more,
um,
uh,
more serious by the departure of troops to fight,
in Alsace.
And also by,
uh,
troop still left in chasing down and rounding up,
the Belgian forces,
uh,
in Belgium.
Um,
but he spends four divisions to,
uh,
Russia as a way.
And also because the Russians have advanced form or rapidly than he thought was
ever possible.
And so one of the things,
uh,
that,
that the German high command does is instead of going,
you know,
all the way this way,
they turned down,
uh,
they turned down south and then,
south east,
uh,
quicker than had been,
originally,
uh,
originally plan,
um,
and despite huge losses on both sides,
the German side in the French side,
and then with the British also getting into the action,
uh,
the,
the German forces are within 35 miles of Paris,
35 miles within Paris,
so that you could hear the cannon in Paris,
uh,
from,
the fighting just east and north of the capital.
Now if one wants an explanation for how the French homefront was able to hold a
spectacularly through the entire war,
uh,
that is one of two key factors and it's the most important,
is that,
uh,
the Germans are so close to Paris,
that they can bombard Paris on Easter Sunday,
1918 more about that later with this huge gun,
big Bertha,
as,
as it was called by the English I firing way down from up here in the north,
uh,
lobbing these huge shells all the way.
Uh,
so the,
the,
the pressure is,
is there,
uh,
and the response is heroic.
The second factor,
which is often forgotten,
is that the,
this union of the Sacred Union,
this union south bay is extremely effective in mobilizing through propaganda,
but also through a extremely intelligent action.
Uh,
bringing helped,
for example,
to,
uh,
two people trying to bring the harvest in a using troops,
and when they have them fairly soon,
a captured German soldiers to help bring the harvest in and they also begin to
give out of costume,
familial or sort of family allocations.
Family resources I guess is a wave of,
of,
of putting that,
uh,
two families,
who the departure of the sons brothers and fathers was a catastrophic,
but of course they hadn't seen anything yet.
Uh,
but they're very shrewd in this and the homefront unlike Berlin.
and that's another story.
Uh,
but the home front,
uh,
in,
in France holds throughout the entire a war.
I mean,
there are some exceptions in that,
and I'm gonna talk about that next week and it's fairly,
um,
uh,
I mean on Wednesday,
it's fairly,
um,
uh,
interesting.
Um,
and so as the Germans are,
are trying to,
you know,
drive to Paris in what became known as the battle of the Marne at the dawn of
Air Warfare,
uh,
planes,
you know,
are their first use of Rocana song.
Rick connaissance,
they're not used for,
for uh,
you know,
it really is weapons.
And,
and the very,
very beginning,
uh,
there are,
you know,
our attempts to drop small bombs and things like that.
And the,
and the French do this,
do this fairly,
uh,
early on in Germany and German cities.
And the Germans do this as well,
but there's a guy flying around up there who are reconnaissance pilot,
uh,
who know,
who noticed that the qcs army is changing,
uh,
directions,
leaving,
uh,
it's flank open as it moves to a point south east of Paris.
And so at that point,
the French rush,
every conceivable soldier into,
uh,
into the battle of,
of the mound,
which takes place basically between nine UAE,
which is a town you can see here,
uh,
and uh,
and,
and Shawn Panio and basically in shuttle on Sham pineal,
uh,
the battle of the Marne,
and,
and everybody knows this.
It's a famous story and there's of course a metro stop named after him
inevitably.
But the,
but the,
the,
the commander of the military defense of the Paris region is a guy called
gasoline,
And he,
uh,
can scripts of the taxis have Paris.
And so the presion taxis literally carry soldiers,
uh,
out to fight in the battle of the Marne,
which can be clearly heard.
To repeat myself,
uh,
in,
in Paris,
uh,
that there was a sense of impending doom,
obviously,
but,
uh,
the miracle occurs,
and,
um,
the,
the British,
uh,
poor through another gap in the German armies of further up along the end river
ais in e,
um,
and,
uh,
for forced them to retreat 40 miles back.
And that's the largest exchange of real estate that would occur until 1918
because of what happens next.
And on September 14th,
along the end river,
uh,
the Germans begin to fortify their position by digging trenches,
um,
and rather like the v the battle of [inaudible] in the French revolution in
1792,
the song culottes that is the ordinary people who defended the revolution.
The Battle of the Marne Saves Paris.
And,
uh,
without a question,
um,
uh,
saves a saved France.
So then what you've got is,
and you have to,
I'm getting,
I always give ridiculous sports analogies,
uh,
but since most of what I did over the weekend was watch football,
it works anyway in this case.
And what you have to do is imagine somebody trying to get outside and a football
game,
a Mychart or somebody trying to get outside,
uh,
and,
you know,
as the,
as the guards pull and as you move toward the outside that the,
the,
the defense and above all the linebackers and everybody kind of moves along.
And what you have basically is you have a race to the sea.
They're trying to out flake each other where the Germans are going back to the
strategy.
Penn by Schlieffen,
uh,
in 1905.
It is.
They're trying to get around to,
to,
to go around and then put this headlock and of course,
what the,
uh,
what the French and the,
and the British are doing is they're racing along also to try to steal,
to keep,
to hold their ports,
the French ports,
uh,
and also to keep them from being out flank.
And so then you have,
I mean the famous western front,
and that's,
we're not talking about the eastern front of,
there's a lot of good work done recently on the eastern front,
but you have this,
this western front is generated so much to me,
no magnificent literature,
some of which you're reading.
And Bob Lewis,
as well as,
as the inevitable,
uh,
all quiet on the western front by Eric Emory,
remark,
uh,
and,
the Siegfried Sassoon and the British war poets.
Um,
now there were a few journalists,
I can't remember if I mentioned this or not,
who had,
who had followed the,
uh,
the Russell Japanese war in 1904 1905.
And they had noticed that in some of these very prolonged battles,
that trenches had been done,
been dug,
and in the mud,
uh,
and just horribly bad weather.
That two forces stared across a no man's land against each other.
And that's exactly what happens in world war one.
And that is to make a very long story,
complicated story and sometimes overly simplified story,
a very short,
that's exactly what happens on the western front is that the spade and the
shovel along with the machine gun,
which is a defensive weapon along with ultimately gas and flame throwers,
there are new ways of dying to,
uh,
become,
the weapons of the war,
uh,
along with artillery,
which in our artillery kills more people than any other weapon followed by,
by machine guns.
And so basically,
as you can see from this map,
uh,
that,
um,
the trenches go all the way from Switzerland literally to,
uh,
to the English Channel.
And that is where a larger ness of France and these other countries where the
youth,
the young men,
uh,
and some older men to have these countries died.
That's,
that was the end where their short lives ended in the vast majority,
uh,
of,
of the cases.
Um,
and attempts in 19,
in the fall of 1914,
uh,
to break through simply don't work.
And it's not too hard to figure out why they don't work.
You don't have to be a specialist in military warfare to know that if you're
going to break through like this and you're getting,
you're going to either side,
you pick your side and you're going to get across.
The question is how are you going to do that?
Because by you very quickly,
uh,
the Germans have lines behind for hears from point of view.
The French,
they,
they're,
they're building railroads they can supply,
uh,
and if you're going to go across and breakthrough,
these are sort of rubber band defenses.
And in order to,
uh,
to,
to break through with the strategy that they adopt a really throughout the wars,
what we are called creeping barrages,
uh,
is that with all of these,
you know,
these,
these tens of thousands of cannons,
you'd have to soften up your opposition by killing many people as possible.
So you're,
you're shelling,
you're anticipating where you're going to go.
And this of course tips off your opponent,
says,
Aha,
that's where they're going to go this time.
Last time they went down there and this time they're coming here.
And so all this does,
I mean,
anybody can see this and you'll see it in a while,
uh,
got live here and not so live,
but,
but we'll see it.
Uh,
uh,
I on your screen is that these creeping barrages besides killing lots of,
you know,
the Americans invented the term friendly fire,
uh,
besides killing their own people.
But what they do is they create these enormous craters,
craters of death that are filled with,
with,
uh,
just awful pestilent waters into and it,
and make it impossible,
uh,
to really get to the other side.
Because once you,
you know,
once somebody goes up and blows the whistle as a follow me and you jump out of
the trenches,
you've got to carry 60 pounds,
60 pounds worth of equipment.
Now that's a lot of equipment down into these things come through these craters.
And then what you do is you find these machine guns,
layers of them to aimed right low,
and they just take you out,
right?
One or after another.
I have been in imperial war museum in London various times,
and I just went to about,
uh,
six weeks again,
a go for the hell of it.
They made it,
they really,
it's not as good as it used to be,
but there,
but there used to be this one clip where,
uh,
you can see these,
these guys,
these three guys,
and one of them is a,
in an officer.
The officer has his whistle and he blows the whistle.
That is,
you know,
on a ball.
Here we,
let's go.
Let's go guys.
And you see him,
he gets one foot over there and he's shot dead.
So you see his body slumped down.
You see the second guy,
you can imagine the terror in his eyes.
You can't see him,
his eyes,
uh,
you don't see him very long,
cause then he's killed two.
And then you'll see the third guy get over and you don't know what happens to
him.
His eyes weren't very good.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this,
this is a story of a,
of the war.
Now there's a vigorous historical debate always.
And did they know what they were doing?
I mean,
there's the image that you will see of course in the movie,
uh,
the paths of glory is that they're,
they are drinking champagne.
And somebody who's,
uh,
confiscated chateau,
and sending runners who were the people who carried messages to the,
to the,
uh,
trenches.
Uh,
and,
and our organizing.
You're organizing these attacks and thus,
you know,
the,
the most famous and,
you know,
just killing fields basically of the war.
And the really famous one was like posh Andale,
which is in,
uh,
in Belgium.
I,
and when you go through this idyllic sir,
part of Belgium near Eip,
I mean,
you can't imagine that,
you know,
tens of thousands of people dying there in a poison.
That's where the Germans first use poison gas.
Um,
or the psalm is the obvious example that everybody uses.
And I will use again in a while and,
or the battle of El done,
uh,
where,
you know,
they're,
you're fighting a hand to hand,
hand to hand combat in the forts of Verdun,
uh,
that,
and it goes simply goes on and on and on.
And there's,
you know,
now the revisionist,
the interpretations of the battle of Passchendaele don't write down plush and
Dale,
it's impossible to spell anyway,
um,
that,
uh,
that say,
well,
if they,
if they'd redefine the idea of the creeping barrage and if they'd managed to
just take a,
you know,
a hundred yards and hold that and the next hundred yards,
et cetera,
et cetera.
But,
uh,
increasingly,
I mean,
it was just clear.
it was obviously the soldiers and it was clear to most anybody that there wasn't
going to be a breakthrough.
Uh,
but the,
the,
the high command,
the German high command and,
and the French high command and,
and the,
the British high command,
uh,
keep insisting that the next one will be the time we will truly break through.
But there isn't any breakthrough until the Germans breakthrough in the spring of
1918.
Uh,
and the bodies get higher and higher.
Now in the eastern front,
you know,
which,
which you had some trench situations,
but basically,
you know,
it's a more wide open kind of fighting.
Uh,
you have,
uh,
it was almost,
there's so many people killed that one of the Russian generalist disparities.
So we don't have any idea how many people killed because a bottle of bodies just
stack up so high.
We can't see anything.
And we,
it's impossible to guests in and the Italian front and the Italian and Austrian
Front Austro-hungarian Front,
there are 10 different battles named after the same river,
the same small river.
And so real estate is exchanged,
uh,
in terms of,
of,
of yards,
not in terms of it's won or lost at the expense of all these lives,
uh,
a of not kilometers.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but yards in kilometers,
gains of a couple of kilometers are,
are,
uh,
celebrated by,
by the hysterical press.
Uh,
I,
I'm both sides and I mean,
these are very old stories,
but it's still true.
I mean the,
that things appeared,
for example,
in the French press,
Heather,
their counterparts elsewhere,
uh,
that,
French bodies that are decomposing don't smell the way German bodies,
uh,
that are decomposing.
That was a one story or that the German,
uh,
shells are so badly made.
The expression was Jerry made.
That is an expression that that came out of World War Two also made by the
Germans because Jerry's was a derogative term for Germans,
that they're just kind of like,
you know,
play things.
They just kind of blow up and go poof.
And that's the end of it.
That they don't really kill a and reports,
uh,
put in the civilian press about,
about the hardy vigorous life of the soldiers because they're in such good
shape,
you know,
cause they're eating well,
which is obviously not the case.
They're eating frozen potatoes.
Uh,
and when the,
you know,
Pete town increases the rum ration,
so they could go over the top,
a little,
a little tipsy to get killed,
uh,
in,
in a val done,
uh,
in 1916.
Um,
so there was this enormous,
and this is one of the themes in the literature of the war.
This is huge discontinuity between the civilian life,
uh,
and the soldiers and the soldiers can't talk about it when they come back.
Uh,
you know,
and they say things like,
uh,
what do they imagine that we jump up every morning and say,
long live France,
long live Germany,
long live Italy,
depending on your case and jump over the top heroically.
Uh,
you know,
in order to get to a,
your name the city,
Moscow,
Berlin,
uh,
Paris,
San [inaudible],
wherever you want to talk about it.
Um,
the,
and so this,
this continuity,
the soldiers when they go on and leave,
when that,
when the soldiers go back to the whorehouses of Mamacita,
uh,
you know,
they,
um,
uh,
or the bars of,
of,
of Montparnasse or anywhere else,
or back to their,
uh,
Doug Leone.
And or anywhere you want,
it's impossible for them to even discuss what has happened.
And indeed,
one of the interesting things about this whole thing is lots of the really great
literature after the war about the war does not come in the first two years.
Uh,
the Bob boosts,
does that mean,
that's fact?
I think he started to,
you know,
in the war,
but,
uh,
all quiet on the western front isn't really written until late in the 1920s.
And then of course,
the,
the Nazis tried to keep it from being shown because it's obviously an antiwar
film,
uh,
in,
um,
uh,
German,
theaters.
So,
um,
well in terms of,
you know,
in 1914,
I mean,
you could just see statistics,
you can just give all these statistics and you can read charts in any book,
including mine.
And it's just,
these are real people,
which is very hard.
It's obvious thing to say,
but it's hard.
It's hard.
It just is the singer,
his fingers are so numbing by the end of the,
of 1914.
So you're talking about half a year.
Um,
the British,
I mean,
the German and French forces had combined casualties of 300,000 killed.
That's three times the number of people filling up the La Coliseum or the rose
bowl or Michigan stadium.
That's a lot of people,
600,000 wounded.
Um,
and,
uh,
and these are many in many cases,
just devastating wounds.
And so it's not so hard to imagine why,
you know,
the Paris metro in the,
in the,
uh,
the subway in the 1920s was full of people begging with one arm or one,
one leg or no legs or coughing out their lungs because of gas attacked.
Um,
the British seventh division arrived in France in October,
1914 with 400 officers and 12,000 soldiers after fighting around IPA,
which IPA has right over the Belgian border,
uh,
up by the English,
not far with an English Channel,
beautiful old textile town.
It was destroyed for obvious reasons during the war.
Um,
they had 400 officers and 12,000 soldiers,
400 officers,
12th thousand soldiers at the end.
After 18 days,
they had 44 officers and 2000,
336 soldiers left.
Figuring out your odds if you're able.
We're 18,
19,
20,
21,
uh,
male in,
19,
uh,
14.
And there's a recent movie which I,
I can't remember the name of it,
my wife was saying,
but it is,
but it's about,
uh,
I,
in 19,
uh,
14,
there was an attempt on Christmas day for people to say that's the fee large
mall.
I mean,
this is just enough of this crap.
Let's sing to each other.
In the Welsh were singing their ballads and the Germans were singing,
uh,
you know,
doleful Lutheran hymns and the,
and the Catholic friends were singing,
you know,
this and that and,
and uh,
then,
um,
uh,
you know,
somebody said,
well,
let's play,
let's play some football.
So they got to,
you know,
I've got soccer players and they out playing and kicking the ball around and
they went back to try to kill each other again.
In 1915,
um,
a British soldier suggested said,
hey,
let's do that again.
Cause he was lucky enough to be around when they're doing it in 1914,
they put him up against the wall and shot him for treason,
treason.
And one of the things that happens during this,
because these people were,
everybody knows all these stories.
You know,
the,
I mean you hear people dying,
you hear them slowly expire.
I between uh,
uh,
you know,
in the craters between the trenches.
And so there are all these rumors that,
that there were all these people that had managed to survive with light wounds
and that there was this huge underground,
a cavern were Germans and French and British were all hanging out and they were
going out and getting wine champagne where they could find it and they were
coming and taking food rations and they were the smart ones cause they were down
there.
Uh,
and you know,
it was the kind of rumor that just went on and on,
but the proximity of death and proximity of the war was Wa was,
was always there.
Again,
the another famous example you could have if you're,
you know,
an officer in the British army,
you could have lunch in the officer's Club at Victoria Station where many of you
have been,
and you could take the train to the front and you could be dead
by,
ah,
in the same front.
You could be dead Co Fini uh,
Covey by,
uh,
by the end of the day,
when Welsh minors,
uh,
tunneled under this big promitory in Belgium,
the explosion could be heard across the English Channel in Kent.
The war was so close.
That's what made it terrifying.
But that's what makes it also because of the people lost,
people,
lost family,
everybody lost family.
That war was the dominant experience of,
uh,
of,
of the 20th century,
at least the first half of the 20th century.
And again,
you can look at the whole period,
1914 to 1945 as this long,
horrible,
30 years' war because the soldiers just simply kept,
kept marching.
Uh,
but they weren't doing much marching in the trenches.
because,
uh,
there was,
there wasn't any word to go,
uh,
you're marching was running out and hoping that you were somehow going to make
it back,
uh,
after yet another,
let's go over,
uh,
over the,
the top.
Uh,
and to repeat,
I mean,
machineguns had first been used,
if I remember right,
they were called Gatling guns in the American civil war.
I think they were used at Gettysburg,
if I'm correct.
Um,
they were slowly perfected,
uh,
at least to the level of world war one.
And they,
after shelling after these big shells,
uh,
launching,
you know,
tens of thousands of shells,
when they're softening up the opponent as to where they're going to go.
I mean,
these,
these things go on for days and that's where the whole,
the whole syndrome of shell shock is a term that comes out of world war one too.
Because a lot of people,
something,
I mean,
there are all sorts of estimates on how many people really lost,
uh,
lost their mental capacity because of all of this.
But,
but not only new ways of dying,
but new ways of just having your head exploding time and time and time again,
a living among the dead bodies,
uh,
comrades who have disappeared,
a rat's,
huge rats,
huge aggressive rats,
mice,
Weiss and everything else.
And then there were,
uh,
you know,
there were a flame throwers and their tanks,
more about tanks.
Uh,
uh,
tanks are,
aren't any good at all,
basically till 1917 because you had a tank,
no matter,
no tank can go over these craters.
They just get stuck in there or whatever.
Then that's their wheels.
I don't know what you call them.
They're treads,
just spin around and,
and,
and they're,
they are.
Um,
and so,
um,
there were,
uh,
there was new,
a new misery.
Uh,
and I did,
you know,
you could send packages,
a little care packages to,
to the soldiers with the little cheese from the owl Dasher,
little sub,
a cheese from Savoie or maybe a bottle of wine from burgundy or something like
that and hopes it didn't get pilfered.
One soldier wrote back before you can have a drink.
You have to chip away the ice.
The meat is frozen and solid.
The potatoes are bonded by and even hand grenades are welded together and their
cases.
That's another weapon to that that,
uh,
comes up.
Uh,
um,
in World War World War One,
a friend,
soldier,
remember we all had honest,
the stench of dead bodies,
the bread we ate,
the stagnant water we drank.
Everything we touched had,
uh,
a rotten smell.
Death simply numbed,
uh,
an Austrian soldier of,
here's some examples I took from other,
other front too,
but why not a violinist?
A violinist wrote a certain fierceness arises in you,
an absolute indifference to anything the world holds except your duty of
fighting.
You're eating across the brand and a man is shot dead in the trench next to you.
You look at them calmly for a moment,
and then you go on eating your bread.
Why not?
There's nothing to be done.
And Yeah,
after having an affair,
I,
in the end,
you talk of your own death with as little excitement as you would as a a
luncheon engagement,
a British,
uh,
one of the war poets road.
I can't remember which one,
but the line sticks with you.
He wrote,
I didn't want to die at least anyway,
until I'd finished.
We are reading the return of the native and then he went on a,
and the dead filled up these,
uh,
these craters
airplanes just as the insertion as they said,
were first used for Rocana,
Rocana sauce.
Uh,
they,
you know,
the pilot's carry pistols and fire up their,
their,
uh,
their opponents.
And again,
there was a server spree decor that,
that,
uh,
these were some of the brave fighting guys up there providing amusements for the
people in the trenches below.
And when one of the aces would get shot down,
the other planes would fly over and drop flowers and a baron von Rick coffin.
And,
and,
and all these,
you know,
big ace guys,
most of whom were killed,
uh,
in,
in the end,
uh,
they get the good idea of instead of putting machine gun on a plane that fires,
and then they found that the machine gun bullets are sent back killing the pilot
by the propeller.
Someone says,
Aha,
let's time it to the propeller.
So they create ways,
they create bigger bombs that you can drop in all of that.
Uh,
but,
uh,
air force planes are basically used for,
for,
uh,
reconnaissance planes.
And the war simply goes on and on.
One of the reasons why it goes on and on by the way,
is,
um,
uh,
you know,
that atrocity stories.
I'm,
I mean,
that's not one reason that goes on and on,
but it's one of the things that that sort of wood would,
if you're going over the top again,
would give you some reason to want to go over the top,
uh,
besides simply trying to survive.
And not wanting to be shot as a dessert or is the atrocity stories,
uh,
of course for the Germans who had in the Franco Prussian war,
there were some cases,
not very many of them being gunned down by civilians who were called
[inaudible],
just civilian sort of sharp shooters.
Um,
and the Germans go into the war with the sense that they better watch it cause
the Belgians are gonna,
you know,
are going to shoot you down from buildings.
Uh,
and so will the French.
most of the atrocities,
uh,
the western front were committed by the Germans,
not by the French.
Uh,
there were,
uh,
at 500,
a Belgian civilians executed most famously the,
uh,
the nurse Adita Cavalla,
who is executed with a couple of other people accused of,
of treasons.
Uh,
there were cases of rape perpetuated by,
uh,
by,
a germ of truth,
but rape had not yet become a weapon of war.
I that would lay wait until,
uh,
later in,
in that very sad,
very sad,
uh,
century.
Uh,
but these,
these,
um,
you know,
these stories,
passed very quickly and were seized upon by propagandas on both sides.
And that sort of keeps folks going.
Okay.
Now what about,
what about Vr done?
Can we,
how do I cut this completely?
Cause they're not gonna be,
we'll see this.
Well,
just have to pretend you're fighting at night.
Maybe that,
can you,
can we fool around with that thing?
Thanks a lot.
I appreciate it.
I'm not very good at that sort of high,
high tech stuff.
Now we can pretend we're finding it day.
There we go.
Anyway.
Uh,
this is from valve done Novell.
Then why did the Germans go after avail done in 1916?
Uh,
they know they're not going to break through,
but again,
it has ultimately to do with,
uh,
that um,
French birthrate is that they know because they have more children.
They can afford to lose more German soldiers.
That is,
if you were in German,
you guys,
then the French,
that is you guys or the British,
you guys,
if you were French or you were a British.
And by the way to say,
guys,
it's not the,
it's not at all to denigrate the role of women in the war.
More about that next lecture to a great extent,
a great extent,
because that's extremely important because somebody had to step up in the
factories and all of that.
Uh,
but they general Faulk and Hein,
the commander,
uh,
simply says we will bleed them so that they will be forced to negotiate and to
sue for peace.
They cannot afford to lose all of the hundred thousands of people that we can
afford to lose.
So,
uh,
at the battle of El done,
the town of Vail de in the moves in northeast,
you know,
from,
uh,
from maps,
itself has,
was,
has been virtually destroyed by,
uh,
by shelling,
and the forts avail down or off to the north end,
to the east.
And they're two of them.
The names don't matter,
but they're interesting.
And some day you should go there.
A vote.
A U X is one,
and the other is called Dewa Mall,
which may be the only French commune that no longer exists.
Do you do a mole?
Should be di do di,
you know,
I can't remember.
D O u a m e n T.
Anyway,
it doesn't matter.
But one of the things when I,
when you go there,
you'll see these plaques that people put up after the war.
And I think I mentioned this the very first day and the hardest to take his is,
uh,
one guy advo he went up,
made a in 21 or 22 of plaque assist to my,
uh,
to my sons since his eyes closed,
might have not ceased to,
to weep.
And so the fighting in the myths of these forests with some of the worst ever
seen in any war and would take hundreds of thousands of lives.
As you know,
this is a member of the stuff about the craters.
This is an aerial view of fort do 'em all,
uh,
the area around there and those are all creators.
It looks like it's your classic,
a lunar landscape.
This is the south entrance to the Fort of Dua Mall,
uh,
which has just been destroyed by,
by German shelling,
as you can see.
And here you have,
uh,
and these are the entrance.
You could go as a tourist,
you can go right into there.
I mean,
these are,
we're not where these plaques are all I'll put up around here,
like they're inside of a church.
Uh,
that's what it looked like.
Then you can see the mall left from do a mall there.
Uh,
the,
the Doula is a sudden he's used to Plu.
It's not there anymore.
And as a matter of fact,
when you go to where the commune was,
uh,
the shelling is such that,
that the,
uh,
you know,
there's a huge heels,
I mean,
enormous hills have been created simply by,
uh,
this,
this land being blown apart.
Uh,
and that you're in,
um,
you know,
you're,
this,
you lived in the fort as you lived in these trenches and the trenches were,
as the forts are accommodated,
as best they can to make things a livable,
uh,
for those who are about to die.
Um,
and here is a,
you know,
an infirmary,
uh,
where you have your instant amputations,
there,
uh,
and,
and that's what it looked like.
And you've seen pictures of the,
of,
of the Somme,
which I'll talk about maybe next time,
a little bit.
Uh,
they had to build the,
these uh,
uh,
these walkways to get you over all of the mud.
And then the weather in northern France.
I,
whether you're talking about Bologna or anywhere else,
you know,
anyone in the channel,
but all the way really into the northern part of Alsace is,
is pretty dreadful.
And here again,
are these craters.
I mean,
you're saying you're going to carry 60 pounds through that stuff.
Uh,
not really easy.
and Barb wire,
which I should have mentioned also,
uh,
is one of those defensive weapons of war along with uh,
along with,
uh,
your,
your basic machine gun.
Um,
and of course one of the things that adds to the weight carried by age soldiers.
You had to have barbed wire clippers that are going to succeed in cutting the
Barb wire and the war poets.
Uh,
you know,
one of them,
I can't remember,
maybe it's Isaac Rosenberger and one of them said that,
well,
where,
where's the finest of Devin?
Sure.
There are hung up there,
hung up,
hung up on that old Barb wire because it was easy to get caught up on the Barb
wire and simply a parish there.
And there's your,
you know,
your basic real live trench,
uh,
with these,
you know,
with,
with the helmets,
the,
the French troops,
by the way,
who'd gone into the war wearing this is true.
I couldn't invent this bright red pants,
uh,
that could be seen a fru the mists by,
troops,
uh,
change to more subtle colors by the end of the war,
to give them a better chance.
And so that was the trench.
And when you were going to attack,
what you would do is climb up over the trench and then face this machine gun
fire and get as far as you could.
Uh,
many did not get very far at all,
uh,
and their,
is,
uh,
you know,
get your head down and hope it doesn't land on you.
That's how most people died.
The majority of people died through Shelan,
uh,
in these kinds of creeping Abraj.
Those are just basic shelling.
I mean sharpshooters uh,
what was also a problem,
that's how the w if many of you have read the all quiet on the western front and
that's how he gets killed at the end.
Uh,
cause he puts his head up and,
and uh,
someone blows it away.
Uh,
but generally they use these kind of periscopes to look up in the survey,
the scene.
And if you went out into the trenches,
it was went out at night is we're connaissance,
uh,
patrols and that was pretty dangerous.
Or if you were particularly heroic,
and many of these people in the infirmary service were,
you went out to try to bring back the wounded before they died.
And that's what,
uh,
I mean,
you have to imagine this as being everything from Switzerland to,
uh,
to the English Channel.
And they are,
they are preparing grenades.
Again,
a lot of people in France and in Germany are hunters and they're used to
shooting.
But the idea of,
you know,
of throwing a grenade,
there's not,
there weren't sports and France then,
I mean,
this is a lame,
and I apologize for this lame analogy,
but,
but the idea of throwing a grenade,
I mean American throw baseballs and stuff like that,
but,
uh,
you know,
it was that even that gesture of throwing something with,
uh,
took a little of,
of getting used to,
but here they are getting ready to go again.
Incoming,
yeah.
Going out at night.
And the other thing is we went out at night.
I mean,
you couldn't see that was part of it and you cause you couldn't be seen.
And of course,
that's where you can get hung up on,
on,
uh,
on Barb wire that you don't know or encounter another patrol,
from,
uh,
from the other side.
Then they tried to fool each other or they get people that,
that,
uh,
you know,
grew up in Alsace to,
to speak German and,
and all of that.
Ah,
and there was a course,
a machine gun,
uh,
in placement,
second big way of,
of,
of getting killed.
Go there sometime,
go,
go and does door devo and do them all and try to imagine what it's like,
Eh,
it must've been just,
uh,
just something.
And also the weather is so heavy,
it's heavy weather,
so they're addressed rather heavily.
These are sort of binocular type things there.
Uh,
and uh,
wow.
Woah.
And that's a sleeping accommodations such as you would find a,
if you look at that,
you could also imagine being in a submarine Auc as much of this is underground
are there,
and then that's where you slept and you try to figure out who didn't come back
after the,
when the night patrol came back.
Okay.
Did a telephone systems,
the Germans had a huge advantage in the east because the Russian telephone
system,
they'd managed to figure out how it works and they could hear every single call
if they were within range.
Uh,
but the,
the French system worked better.
I,
and,
um,
you know,
I mean,
we also,
we're dealing with telegraph,
so I mean this,
this is modern warfare.
What made it total warfare was the mobilization of an entire society of its
productive capacity,
uh,
to fight this war on and on and on and on.
And of course,
how the war ends with the German troops way inside France,
we'll have enormous repercussions for the poisoning of the 19 20th in 1930s
because it became easy for Hitler to say,
and for other,
he was just wonderful.
Lots of right wing leaders to say,
we were winning the war.
How do we lose it?
We're inside France.
We were stabbed in the back.
The dolch stuff's by who?
The Jews,
the Communists,
the socialists,
the weak ones,
not part of the true national volkist community,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
and bring somebody back.
He thought,
I'm sorry to say the man looked a little Pekin,
uh,
hauling them back.
And these are guys,
these are armed soldiers.
So this is not your infirmary group.
There were some respect of,
of the red flag until,
I mean the Red Cross insignia Signia and the white flag.
Ah,
people tended to respect that.
And also across the know there were these images,
uh,
in a place called Alabama,
like Albert,
a town in the town,
in the song that was completed,
destroyed.
There was a statue of the Virgin Mary on top of a church and it was hit by a
shell and it was hanging by a thread and the soldiers on both sides could see
that the Virgin Mary hanging by a Fred and everyday people think it's going to
get a hit again.
It's going to fall down.
And it became that too became this sort of myth about if it fails,
they're going to be that showed that France is going to lose.
And,
and all of that are,
and a lot of these towns like a Haas,
uh,
and um,
harass,
uh,
the gift.
That's how they get to eat a lot of Ras,
which is one of the great cathedrals in Europe or anywhere else,
uh,
was destroyed because they're right on the front,
right on the front.
And again,
infirmary,
there's infirmary guys there.
Okay.
And uh,
I don't know what these people are.
They're distributing water.
That's what they're doing there is drawing water,
getting ready to go charge over that.
The ones who didn't make it.
Okay.
There's still a whole trench of with band that sticking up that they more or
less left away.
It was,
you see that too.
They removed the bones and that's the night patrol going out,
crawling over those craters.
It gives you a pretty good idea.
See the movie
explosions,
why that last one,
by the way,
it was simply called [inaudible] hell,
which is the way it a way it was.
So we're going to pass on to not necessarily more cheery subjects.
Uh,
next time about,
we'll talk about why 1917 was the big year I,
and,
uh,
I would talk about the end of the war and what all that meant and again,
to discuss the impact of all of this on French society.
See you Wednesday.